this is the ramsay show
[Applause]
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studio it's the ramsay show
where america hangs out to have a
conversation about your life and your
money i'm ramsay personality george
campbell joined today by the infamous dr
john deloney host of the dr john daloni
show best-selling author and we are here
to take your calls open phones this hour
triple eight eight two five five two two
five we'll talk about money
relationships what you're stressed out
about around the holidays your mental
health anxiety
emergency funds debt you name it
we are here for you john
now we're not here for you we're here
for them i'm talking about comma john
i'm here for you george thank you and
we're here for them i appreciate that
how's your friday going it's good man
you've got you've got some book
deadlines coming up don't you we are
cranking it does it feel like high
school again where you're cramming for
the big test except in high school
nobody reads your papers oh this one's a
paper that millions of people read a
little different yeah it's a little
different a little more puckered up but
we'll get there we'll get there all
right let's go to the phones we've got
gene in rochester new york gene welcome
to the ramsay show
hi thank you for taking my call can you
hear me okay you sound great how can we
help okay um so i'll give you a little
bit of a back story i'm 65 years old and
retired i don't owe any money
i have about 3 000 a month in bills and
um giving and i my total income coming
in is 5 300. i only have 43 000 in an
ira and i want to continue to invest so
that i can offset the cost of living
when i'm older i'm wondering if you
could give me some guidance on how much
i should be putting away
absolutely well you've got some leftover
money so you're in a good spot here with
just having some excess so your bills
and expenses are 3 000 and you have 5300
coming in so you have excess of 2 300
freed up right now
that's correct where do you get where do
you get that 5 000 bucks what are you
doing
oh um that's a combination of pension
and social security outstanding good
okay good good good and you're wondering
hey how can i invest this excess so that
i can use it in retirement and live into
my 90s
i'd like to know how much of it because
some of it i want to have a little fun
with and but i know i need to put some
of it away so i'm wondering what a good
ratio would be
yeah well 50 50.
it really depends on your lifestyle your
comfort level it sounds like these 3 000
expenses it's going to stay like this do
you have a you you said you don't have
any debt do you have a mortgage or
anything like that
no i've paid everything off wow gene way
to go
thanks i feel pretty good about it you
sure you should be smiling from ear to
ear
this is awesome it was a long haul yes
i'm really happy about it thank you when
you say you want to go have some fun
what are you thinking of what kind of
fun you want to have
um i'd like to take vacations which i
haven't done in a long time
and you know i
buy things for the house go out with my
friends
just things like that i love it well
this is going to be a line item in your
budget and so decide hey how much do i
want to set aside for vacations let's
say that number's 5 000 6 000 how much
do i think i'll spend you know going out
each month with friends or whatever
those things might be and make that a
line item in your budget and then the
rest of it i want you to be investing
you can invest into that uh ira
continually so that it can continues to
grow and you can eventually pull money
from that when you need it but right now
you have this guaranteed income so
you've got a good situation here you may
not need to touch the retirement money
for a long long time it sounds like
that's why i was thinking that i could
perhaps put a thousand a month away
um and then
use it in the future to just draw off a
little bit
you know to offset cost of living as i'm
75 85. yeah that's twelve thousand
dollars a year and if you get a rate of
return of you know ten eleven percent on
that and some good growth stock mutual
funds and ira then you'll be able to
pull from that later on in life if you
need to and right now you have fifty
three hundred dollars forever guaranteed
right right that's correct well you're
in good shape
mess around with social security and it
dropped oh that's true you never know
these days you know
well
we usually tell people to split it in
those three categories you're already
doing giving and that's already in your
budget and the other two are spend and
save
and so you're saying it right here i
want to have some fun i don't want you
to just invest every single penny you're
not in a destitute situation so have
some fun go on some vacations but be
wise about the ratio there's no exact
ratio i'm going to tell you hey do 50
here 50 there
but just feel it out and go is this in
line should i be going on a 50 000
trip maybe not but can i go on a 5 000
trip sure and if you do it all with cash
and you don't go into debt you've put
yourself in a fantastic position that
most people your age have not and so you
have the benefit of having a little bit
of freedom here
all right that sounds good thank you
very much yeah thanks so much for the
call gene all right let's go to john in
chicago illinois john welcome to the
ramsay show
hi how are you guys doing doing great
how can we help
um so my question is uh because right
now i work a job that pays a mortgage
and you know i can use that to start the
baby steps
but it's not really you know i don't
really feel
like super happy about it so
i've been talking to some of my
contractors that services my buildings
and they
some one of the guys said he was
watching me to get into a labor union to
become like an electrician or
like hvac and i'm wondering if because i
don't want to use his film vouching for
me and just kind of let it go but if i
do do it seriously
should i get into that and you know risk
me you know having a pay cut for at
least two years because i'm going to be
an apprentice for at least two years and
but what kind of paycheck are we talking
what are you making now and what would
you go down to
well right now i make 25 and he was
saying apprentices right now make around
15.
is that per hour
uh yes okay
so that that's a big jump to be going
down ten dollars an hour from 25 to 15
for two years what are your family
responsibilities right now financially
uh well i'm the bread giver um my uh
well i guess my girlfriend she well we
have three kids together and um she got
a job being like a kinder care teacher
but um
i
pay for most of the bills and
i live a very normal life and i'm trying
to get out of that but i want to make
sure that i can at least give my kids
the best opportunities that they can
when they grow up
before i'm 30 and i'm 28 28 now so i'll
tell you i have taken a pay cut at
multiple opera in multiple steps of my
career
making good money step back to
whether it's because i was changing a
location um and i had growth potential
there or i was gonna enter into a
training program i was gonna go to grad
school i was gonna go to another grad
school whatever that looked like i've
done that multiple times it's worked out
every single time for me that that was a
good financial move
um and every time i made one of those
moves it also had family implications
too
um it's really gonna as far as i know
man it's gonna depend on
can you guys afford to take this cut can
you pay your bills and eat will your
wife work two or three jobs on top of
what she's already doing so that you can
go to do this apprenticeship debt-free
and then you can cross that line i don't
have any problem with you taking a break
for a couple years to make less money to
get trained up to go make more money at
another job but man you got to be smart
don't go into any more debt yeah clean
up this mess stick with this job until
you have the financial freedom to make a
jump like that this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
i've got it for years i've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free shipping with
blinds.com there's no need to renovate
your entire home just change out what's
on your windows with upscale choices
like faux wood blinds cellular and
roller shades or even outdoor shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
all right guys the christmas countdown
is on and we are having a great time
handing out cash as part of our
christmas cash giveaway it's one of my
spiritual gifts to give away dave's
money and if you didn't know giving is
some of the most fun you'll ever have
with money and every year here at ramsey
solutions we celebrate christmas with
our ramsay show listeners with an
awesome tradition our ramsey christmas
cash giveaway and this year we're giving
away 500 every single week and a grand
prize of five thousand dollars you can
enter every single day to increase your
chances of winning just go to
ramseysolutions.com
giveaway and look we know you're
planning to do a lot of giving too
that's why our team has put everything
on sale we've extended our biggest cyber
monday sale until to last till the end
of the week so you can get up to 79 off
right now we've got special deals for
everyone on your list it's the perfect
day to get christy wright's 2022 goal
planner john deloney's conversation
cards question for humans and ken
coleman's career assessment because
these are the lowest prices you're going
to see all year
so hurry up get gifts for your friends
and family maybe even yourself because
our sale ends real soon shop our biggest
cyber monday sale yet at our online
store at ramseysolutions.com
open phones this hour triple eight eight
two five five two two five i'm george
campbell joined today by my colleague
john deloney we're taking your calls and
tobias is on the line in trenton new
jersey tobias welcome to the ramsay show
hi how you doing good how are you how
can we help
great uh so i inherited money when i was
a
young boy
and uh
now
it was put in mutual funds for me and
now it's got about eighty thousand
dollars in there
and i'm looking to buy a house
somewhat in the near future i wanna know
if i should continue contributing for
that so you've been contributing to this
mutual fund on top of what was inherited
no oh okay
so where are you at financially how old
are you and do you have any debt
currently
i don't have debt i'm free
and um 27 years old awesome do you have
an emergency fund of three to six months
saved
yes
fantastic and that's outside of all of
the inheritance you have here tobias man
you're crushing it brother goodbye to
you man
thank you
so you want to use this money to
possibly buy your first home
correct and you're in new jersey have
you looked around to see what houses
cost around there
yeah it's pretty crazy here just like
the rest of the world but uh
is it like three four hundred grand what
are you looking at right now
yeah some yeah yeah
around four or four fifty okay and
what's your income
uh fifty thousand dollars 50k
well that 80k could be a good down
payment and i'll give you some
parameters so that you make the right
decision here and what we recommend is
that you save up that down payment to be
about 10 or 20 percent of the value of
the home i love 20 because that helps
you avoid pmi private mortgage insurance
which is money that protects them not
you it protects the lender and so if you
can get to that point where that 80k is
20 and here's the other factor
i want the
i want you to get a 15-year fixed-rate
mortgage no more than that where the
payment is no more than a quarter of
your take-home pay so crunch some
numbers on that 50 000 you make what do
you actually take home divide that into
four and that's what you can afford
based on the down payment so that might
mean you take that 80k and you save some
money on top of that to get to the
number that's comfortable for you
okay i know i know that you guys don't
say to invest in the
in the market
short term less than three to five years
so i'm wondering if i should contribute
to this fund so it could grow more
before i do yeah what's that what's the
time horizon are you looking to do this
in the next one or two years or is this
four five six years from now
two to three years is the mris
yeah under three years i get a little
hesitant because there's a lot that
could happen in the market and there's a
chance that it could dip and so if
you're if you've got a set timeline for
this that's a little bit risky to be
putting in the market i mean your mutual
funds are already in the market so i
don't mind you contributing to this to
add to it
and watching it grow but i'd give it
three plus years and at that point you
could have you know 150 grand in there
which is going to give you a great down
payment and it'll
with 50k income you'll actually be able
to afford a mortgage payment in new
jersey which is pretty cool well and
just
you you can put it in that account when
i when i was going to buy a house if
there was about two years i had lead
time i just wouldn't open an account at
a credit union man and my goal wasn't to
make a bunch of money on the cash it was
just to
store it in a safe place until i was
ready to use it all you know what i mean
yeah
so i should take it out i would leave it
in there for now but when like what john
is saying is once you get close you're
like hey i'm within a year of getting
this house i would cash it out and put
it in a money market account a
high-yield savings account just park it
somewhere safe that you have access to
to where it's not in the market to where
it's not um you know subject to all the
risk
all right thank you yeah thanks so much
for the call man appreciate it
lori joins us in dayton ohio lori
welcome to the ramsay show
hello hey how are you
good how are you doing great how can we
help today
well um
i have a question really about budgeting
and saving for like big ticket items or
or retirement
we we don't have any debt um but we just
we just have a hard time we pay cash for
everything but we just seem to have a
hard time like buckling down
and getting that savings in the bank
like we need to for the big ticket items
so you're talking about like a sinking
fund where you say all right we need to
save 600 we're going to save 100 a month
for six months
but well it's our emergency fund
and my husband has his own business so
we don't have health insurance
and you don't have health insurance
right now
no
oh boy
this you just got a new priority
today on this friday afternoon
when you when you say when
ever a couple says we we are just really
struggling
is it you is it him
one of you is probably on board and one
of you is probably a little bit wheeling
and dealing
no no we're no we're both on board okay
we are but i mean we haven't had health
insurance for well since our young since
my
19 year old was a year and a half
and you're playing roulette
yeah
but when it comes it comes to budgeting
who blows the budget
well i would say we just have a lot of
expenses
and
we um
we had some a couple financial we've had
to start over pretty much like two times
and i i think we just kind of
like deer in the headlights you know and
so we just kind of like don't know what
to do so we just don't do anything
what kind of budget are you guys doing
right now are you using every dollar are
you doing an excel spreadsheet is this
on paper
it's it's on paper and i yeah i i i do
it i basically do it yeah we've got
everything on automatic payment you know
you're saying whatever happens on paper
does not match reality
i'm just saying there's really just not
a i just don't know what to do
here's what i want you to do because i
want you lori
sometimes when we have major life events
major setbacks or when life just control
alt deletes us right we have a plan
we're moving along down the road all of
a sudden it just rattles our cage
whatever happens the car falls apart kid
gets sick husband passes away whatever
it is
that what you said you described it
perfectly that deer in headlights that's
that's a neurological issue your brain
just goes into neutral for a season it's
called grief
okay
here's what i want you and your husband
to do
only all to go out
together okay you can go to breakfast
together i like that our friend anthony
loves dinner whatever it is you all go
by yourself and plan to spend a few
hours
and i want you to take a notepad
and i want you to look at each other and
be honest and have no electronics
and i want you to talk about and write
down get out of your head
and put on paper
here's our frustrations here's the
milestones we missed
here's where i'm getting stuck here's
where i feel like i can't move i want
you to get it out of your body get out
of your head get out of your heart get
onto paper so you can look at it
and then when i want you when you write
these stories down whatever these
stories happen to be i want you to
demand evidence from these stories is
this true are we really never going to
be able to get back on track no you
can't
am i really the worst spender ever nope
i had a bad couple of years and tomorrow
everything changes and i want you to
come up with a new plan together on
paper you're going to commit at this
dinner this is the moment that we change
everything
and then you're going to go get health
insurance for god's sake
hey lori hang on i'm going to have
austin our phone screener pick up and
give you guys a year to ramsey plus
that's going to give you access to every
dollar our budgeting tool and financial
peace university go through the videos
do the budget with him get on the same
page and you guys will find some
progress thanks for calling it
[Music]
if you're ready to get out there and
find a job you love then you need to
hear this
job hunting can be stressful and time
consuming but my friends at ziprecruiter
have made the whole job search way
easier ziprecruiter is rated the number
one job site in the us by g2 and it's
free so how does it work first go to
ziprecruiter.com
ken
then create a free profile and let their
technology do the hard work by finding
and sending you jobs that are a great
fit and get this
zip recruiter pitches your profile to
companies whose jobs match your skills
and experience if someone from that
company likes your profile they can
personally invite you to apply for the
job so if you're ready for an easier job
search check out ziprecruiter sign up
for free right now at ziprecruiter.com
ken that's
ziprecruiter.com
ken sign up today absolutely free and
let zip recruiter work for you
[Music]
i'm george campbell joined today by my
co-host john delony this is the ramsey
show
and on the debt free stage in the lobby
of ramsey solutions zach and jessica
join us how are you guys good you look
like a debt-free couple to me yes
i love it where are you guys from
indianapolis indianapolis wonderful well
thanks for making the trip to nashville
to do your debt-free scream thank you
let's get into this how much have you
paid off 222 thousand dollars what you
look like you're seventeen
that's amazing how did you have that
much time to rack it up that's
impressive okay how long did it take um
four years and nine months wow
okay and your range of income during
that time uh started at 60 and then made
our way to 142. whoa did someone get a
job this guy
yeah he did you got to redeemed yourself
oh man who's got two thumbs and got a
job you were waiting on that jessica
weren't you
what do you guys do for a living um i'm
a mortgage loan advisor and um jess is a
doctor of physical therapy wow both of
you all have been pretty bored the last
two years
wow very congratulations good folks so
what type of debt was this
mostly student loans from the doctorate
so is that all you then yeah nice i like
how you waited till she answered that
question
i'll let her take this
did you have any part in the debt here
um i i um said yes to getting a car that
we couldn't afford and uh put some money
on our credit card that we didn't have
so there's a little bit of car loan
credit cards on here
totally normal yeah wow
okay so we gotta get into this four
years and nine months ago you guys were
sitting there with 220 000
and you decided nah we're not going to
live like this anymore what happened
um so as we were going through school we
actually had some friends who are here
with us today and they um
explained how they paid off their debt
with ramsey's
just baby steps and so we knew as soon
as school ended that
that was what we wanted to do that we
weren't going to wait and we were going
to pay them off as quickly as we could
so
we didn't really know what that was
going to look like or how long but we
had a slogan that we were going to be
debt-free by 33.
and so but then as it kept getting
closer and closer we're like oh man like
okay let's do it before we're married
for 10 years which is next december um
and then we were like i think we can be
done before the end of this calendar
year and um just
and the numbers never added up to us it
was that's how we knew like it was god
working was that it just didn't make
sense on paper how it was getting paid
and
it just the snowball works so how old
are you wow thirty-one yeah thirty-one
wow
i'm a hip-hop artist too oh gosh we'll
save that for another show that's right
that's so incredible so who who who sat
down and started the conversation one of
you has to have the courage to say hey
we can't live like this i said i took
out these loans and i kept getting
recommendations to apply for the
forgiveness program and
to find a job that qualified for it and
i just said no like i took these out and
somebody paid it so it's our job to pay
it back and
i don't know how it's going to work but
we're going to do it zach you married
well my brother yes a woman of integrity
that's incredible thank you so what did
that journey look like for you guys four
years and nine months were there
sacrifices what kind of things did you
do to actually get out of here or not do
um
so we moved back from california which
is where just went to school we knew
that we wanted to move home to indiana
just for living expenses are a lot
cheaper there um
moved in immediately with my parents we
didn't buy a house right away um
i used va benefits when we actually did
get the the house to make sure that we
were in a good loan and everything like
that and then um
you just said no to a lot of people lots
of no's after that lots of not traveling
not um getting new cars and that sort of
stuff like that so our cars together
over 600 000 miles so that's our next
that's our next step is saving up for a
new car but right now they're both still
working so
we're driving them yeah what is it like
pulling up to
like the rehab center
next to all those
incredible cars yeah and yours has got
green smoke coming out the back of it i
know i keep telling my co-workers i'm
like it's worth it it's so worth it and
i have a couple that did it before me
and we have a couple that are they're
just not sure that they can do it but
we're like no you can like so it doesn't
phase you no good for
you so did people think you were crazy
yes oh yeah yeah for sure plenty of
people yeah there's a lot of friends
co-workers in the mortgage industry
people you're paying off your debt while
you're
yeah that's um that's one of the things
i get a lot is i mean hey you you're
doing pretty well why don't you buy a
new car your car has 400 000 miles on it
you know it's like hey it's only a seven
minute drive if i break down i can walk
i'm good um but yeah it is a lot of hey
what are you gonna use that next bonus
check on what are you gonna do for this
i was like well our plan you know before
we got that free was hey well we want to
put this much towards debt this month we
want to put that much towards that this
this coming month and
so a lot of people were just like man
why are you working so hard like because
we want to be done with this and it's
just one of those things where getting
to talk to people about mortgages and
how you can you know use that as a tool
to help people get out i tell so many
people on the phones about the snowball
method it's so fun it's fantastic that's
awesome
so you guys were on this journey for a
long time yeah did you ever feel like i
don't know like let's slow this down or
did you only just ramp up and get more
excited yeah there were definitely
moments where we were like oh man i
don't know like it we definitely feel
like god's blessing this journey but is
this hard and the podcast the dave
ramsey podcast is honestly like that's
what we would always go to like we would
go on a run put on the podcast and like
just listen to the stories of people
that did it and we actually had two
classmates who also did the debt-free
scream and we just would listen to their
story and like okay we can do this and
we have a bunch of like classmates that
we graduated with that we're all kind of
doing it together and so when we see
them we we check in with each other like
how's it going and we all have young
kids too so we're kind of in the same
phase of life and that that helped a ton
i saw those those two beautiful kids on
the screen in here yes
so what's what's what's it like in your
souls thinking the understanding that
they're never going to understand what
you all went through yeah that's that
guilt that shame that
pi you know just being under that big
blanket yeah the weight i mean for us
it's a big tool that we can use to
explain the gospel to them to how god
paid our debt and just for them to
change their like to never know that
right to just
do things completely different to do it
weird right like to not be normal and um
yeah just to change our family tree that
was kind of the big thing we kept going
back to was
we want the girls to live differently
than than we did what an incredible
couple i'm so proud of you guys
i know they just it really did cheer up
my spirit here off air if you could talk
to george you mentioned that you run
he's not big into exercise but maybe you
can teach him a few things
i paid my debt i'm not running anymore
john
well we've got a copy of
dave's new book baby steps millionaires
that's the next chapter in your story i
mean you guys are 31 years old
completely debt free incredible income
you got these sweet little kids you guys
are going to be millionaires before you
know it yeah that's incredible we also
have a copy of the total money makeover
so that you can pass it along and maybe
get one of those people who thought you
were crazy on board to do this plan get
them running and listening to the ramsay
show podcast thank you thank you this is
fantastic well let's get to it the
moment we've all been waiting for
zach and jessica from indianapolis
220 000 paid off in four years and nine
months making 60 up to 142 thousand
dollars
count it down let's hear a debt free
scream
three two one we're debt free
[Music]
look at those smiling faces
unbelievable man that didn't that just
warm your heart
yeah they're just an incredible couple
i'm like i feel like i'm not a good
person after talking with people like
that they're just they're they're ten
years ahead of me when it comes to
maturity yes maturity most children are
they're that's very fair well played um
but they are incredible yeah
the fact that they
i mean they dug themselves a big hole
and then they had the courage to
call reality reality and say we got to
do something about this and then they
man they worked for four years and made
it happen yeah most people in their 20s
they've got 220 000 in debt they just go
yeah i mean it's not real it's monopoly
it's monopoly money well you know we'll
go to the grave with the student loans
we'll just bank on forgiveness for the
next decade and they just decided to
make a choice and i love when she said i
took that loan out it was up to me to
pay that loan back i remember feeling
that exact same thing that level of
personal responsibility is huge awesome
man super proud of you guys zach and
jessica way to go this is the ramsay
show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
open phones this hour triple eight eight
two five five two two five i'm george
campbell joined today by dr john dolone
give us a call about your life your
money your mental health your
relationships whatever you wanna talk
about we are here for you our question
of the day comes from blinds.com find
out for yourself why blinds.com is the
number one online retailer of custom
window coverings you get free samples
free shipping and with the new promos
they run every month you'll save even
more use promo code ramsey to get the
best deal today's question comes from
hannah in maryland
hannah asks how do i guide my boyfriend
in making a pivotal career move
i get to stop you right there and say
you don't but we'll continue he's 32 and
in residency
most doctors go for clinical careers but
his passion lies in medical research
the problem oh this is great the problem
is that a career in medical research
pays significantly less than a clinical
career
research grants pay about 60 grand a
year and allow you to do clinical work
making up to another
hundred thousand dollars a year
a strictly clinical career starts at
about three hundred thousand and goes up
from there if money was not a factor he
would choose the research career he has
500 000 in student loans we'd like to
get married and have a big family
someday
how do i help him make sense of what he
would be giving up by going with the
lower paying option
how does one weigh their passions with
what makes financial sense is this a
case where passion needs to be thrown by
the wayside
there's so much here
there's a lot going on john
i'll let you go first
hannah
you have already spent 500 000
of your future husband's
first year salary you've already spent
it you know what the house is going to
look like the cars
you already have the picture in your
head of how many kids you'll have and
what they'll all be doing in the big
house that you'll have
on the acres and the wherever and
wherever and wherever
this is less a question about your hus
about your boyfriend's passion
and moral question about do you love him
enough to follow him into what he wants
to do with his life
or do you love him because he's going to
make you a whole whole whole bunch of
money
now he's racked up 500 grand in student
loans right now he because y'all aren't
married he has a a problem he dug
himself a big old hole so if he was to
call in the show i would tell him
um it sounds like i would do both i
would be exhausted and do a clinical
career and do research on the side until
i could get this thing paid off and then
lean over and if he really wants to do
research you can do both in fact i think
the true res the researchers of the most
validity are those who are also seeing
patients um
that's a whole other conversation but
yeah he's gonna have to figure that out
financially
but that's not the question you're
asking question you're asking is can i
marry somebody who doesn't make that
much money
um yeah it feels to me that there's
there's a security thing here of well if
i marry someone who makes 300 000 i'd
feel a lot better than if they made 160.
i don't even see it as a security issue
as much as a she's living in a she's got
a fantasy yeah
and you may have you may have put your
time in you may have invested in this
guy because he was going to be a big
fish
but
i mean 160k is still a great salary and
i'd rather be married to someone who
loves what they do every day and comes
home with something left in the tank
than someone who goes i hate this but
i'm glad we make good money
yeah so i'm heading off to a thing that
i hate and hope you enjoy spinning it
and again
there's much more at play here hannah
you've got to ask yourself can i be with
a guy who only makes a only makes 160.
most people are rolling their eyes going
oh my gosh it's 160 grand i know yeah
yeah knucklehead's got 500 000 student
loans he's gonna have to solve that
problem but you need to have a broader
conversation about is this the guy that
you want to be married to
can you slum it with a guy that just
makes 160
and you all need to be serious about
planning what your finances are going to
look like and when it comes to a budget
and
all those realistic things but you can
how do i guide my boyfriend making a pur
pivotal career move away from his
passion and what he wants to do
that's going to make him six figures
into
how much money cost me yeah
well thanks for the question hannah
appreciate that let's go to the phones
this hour brendan joins us in chicago
illinois brendan welcome to the ramsey
show
hey good afternoon guys thanks for
taking my call sure how can we help my
question today my question today is my
wife of 16 years and i have decided that
we're going to separate
and
we we just recently went over the
finances and we want to just split
everything 50 50 including uh
seeing the children and she we see that
i should be able to get about 325 000
and i wanted to know if i should
when i move out because she's going to
keep this house
if i should just buy a house outright or
just pay for half and save the rest or
what i should do do you have well let me
back up number one 16 years man
how are y'all doing that's a big deal
yeah um our our relationship has been
pretty bad for the past couple of years
um i think she's just tired of being i
guess unhappy so
she just wants to try to move on
i'm
sorry i know that um
this happens all the time and we think
we've just become numb to it and norms
but uh this is a big deal are y'all
separating for a season or is that a
nice way of saying she's filed for
divorce and y'all are getting officially
divorced
legally divorced so i asked i asked her
that the other day and i think right now
we're just gonna separate um and not
immediately get a divorce but it may
lead to that um like i said she's been
unhappy for many years she said so i'm
not sure where it's gonna lead
so i want you guys have you all gone to
mediation if y'all sit down with
somebody
no not yet okay um so i don't know she
wants to avoid seeing a lawyer so i'm
not sure of course it sounds like she
wants to avoid all of it she likes she
wants to
just she wants to play divorced and have
the benefits of what she thinks are the
benefits of divorce without the reality
of it without the finality of without
the pain of it
and yeah perhaps yeah yeah and so she
wants to avoid any professionals telling
her yeah you got to make a decision if
you're going to
split your family up then you can't you
can't string that thing along you got
little ones too
yeah we got a 14 year old and a 9 year
old both girls yeah brother they can't
don't don't put them through that
through a maybe or
we'll see and uh well you know don't do
that to them
and i know i'm i'm preaching to the
choir here i know you've had that
conversation um dude if you're if you're
not officially divorced legally divorced
you you don't buy nothing
do you have 325 000 that she's just
gonna write you a check i mean how y'all
gonna put that up without selling your
house yeah yeah it's cash assets
okay yeah if i'm you i wouldn't really
go ahead i work part-time right right
now only um that's what i've been doing
the last year and a half and she's kind
of the breadwinner of the family so
i wanted to make sure i can afford
something as well
yeah so you've got legal rights you've
got alimony rights and that's i say
she's wanting both sides of she wants to
you know have her cake and eat it too
she
you need to go talk to somebody okay
yeah okay and um sounds like you're
about to get taken advantage of and
ultimately at the end of the day my
brother um
if you were if this was a clean divorce
she was gonna hand you 325 thousand
dollars in cash and send you on your way
i would tell you don't buy anything for
at least a year
you're gonna have to grieve this mourn
this figure out what's next you're gonna
have to get a full-time job it may not
even end up being in this town even
though you want to see your kids the
whole thing man your whole life is gonna
is gonna have to have to control all
delete right
so uh don't buy anything don't lock
yourself into anything even though you
got that money sitting there don't let
it burn a hole in your pocket
go slow grieve this thing talk to
somebody make sure you got friends in
your life
spend really direct quality
no screens time with your kids and
you're gonna have a season of healing
right am i right
yeah yeah for sure so
are you recommending that i i for sure
just make sure to see a lawyer
if i'm you i would i would have a lawyer
on the phone by monday morning at nine
o'clock in the morning
no question no ifs ands or buts
especially if you've been stay at home
while she's been working you helped when
she was in grad school or whatever you
know um
yeah it's pretty convenient to say hey i
just want you to move out and i'll write
you a check to move out but we're not
going to do anything official
because then i'm going to have to
come up with a lot more money yeah this
this divorce turns this thing into a
transaction i want to make sure that
you're protecting yourself as well here
but yeah rent for a year like john said
take it easy don't make any big
financial decisions right now and uh
we're rooting for you man sorry you're
going through this that puts this hour
of the ramsey show in the books my
thanks to my co-host dr john deloney our
phone screener austin selby our phil and
producer here ben hill doing a great job
james charles sitting in as well and you
america thanks for listening we can't do
this without you we'll be back with you
before you know it until then spend
wisely save intentionally and give
generously
this is james childs producer of the
ramsay show did you know the ramsay show
is one of the most popular podcasts in
the world subscribe or follow today
wherever you listen to podcasts
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career
you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studio it's the ramsey show
where america hangs out to have a
conversation about your life and your
money
i'm george campbell joined today by
ramsey personality dr john deloney and
we're here to take your calls the number
is triple eight eight two five five two
two five we can talk about your life
your money your relationships
holiday spending how to get the best
deal how to fix broken relationships and
maybe get rid of some anxiety around the
holidays some of the baggage that's
going on
i can't imagine john all the people
going to their families and not excited
about it you know what i yeah there's
definitely that especially when it comes
to christmas i heard something this year
that i haven't heard ever
i've heard i heard more people opt out
and they when you ask them hey how's
thanksgiving
they were just overcome with joy like i
did nothing i just had like our
neighbors came over and we just ordered
pizza it was amazing or we cooked and it
was low-key and i i i've not heard that
level usually it's like oh well we had
to drive and do this it was fine they're
setting boundaries and making choices
they're good for them yes
well let's go to the phones this hour
andrew joins us in charlotte north
carolina andrew welcome to the ramsay
show
hey how you guys doing doing great how
can we help today
okay so um i actually started financial
peace university two days ago awesome
way to go man welcome to the gang dude
thanks uh so i'm on baby step two
and i'm a little hung up um so i have 33
000 in debt
uh 23 of which are student loans and 10
is in a car
i just sold my car um so just kind of
trying to hit this as aggressively as
possible but
i do have
thirty thousand dollars in savings uh
just in a savings account and i'm kind
of wondering how much i should throw at
that debt um and there's a caveat to
that
i'm the only source of income for my my
house i have two kids and my wife stays
home with my young kids so just trying
to figure out how much of that i throw
with that debt
yeah well you want the good news or the
bad news
i'll take the bad news first they're
both the same it was a trick question
if you go through financial peace
university you're going to learn very
quickly the baby steps and this is
what's changed millions and millions of
lives including families like yours who
have one income who have kids it's what
changed my life john deloney's life and
here's how it works in baby step one you
save up a thousand dollars and clearly
you have that you have thirty thousand
dollars
here's where it gets interesting baby
step two we tell you to take everything
but that thousand and throw it at the
debt and so for you
that means taking 29 000 of your 30 and
throwing it at your 33 000 worth of debt
now where does that leave you right it
leaves you with four thousand dollars in
debt and money back in your life to
attack that remaining debt so hang on
one second i i hear it in your voice man
that puckers you up doesn't it
yeah you don't like you get a little
nervous
yeah
just um the
the fact that you know what what if i
lost my job exactly
it should that's the point
the point is it should it should it
you're in an emergency imagine if you
lost your job and you got money in the
bank but you owe 30 something thousand
dollars
right right you are you're living a
liability
it should freak you out
get it done and then sprint to get this
sucker paid off and to refill that
emergency fund
gotcha it should be a fire in your soul
my kids aren't okay because i owe other
people their money
our money
you hear what i'm saying okay
yeah and that thousand dollars that's
just temporary and right now you're
gonna you're gonna be debt free within a
few months am i wrong if you do it this
way
no it'll be wrecked and then what you're
gonna do is save up that three to six
months of expenses really fast and so
we're talking maybe six months more
after that to get to that point
right and then if you're really puckered
up go deliver pizzas at night
take four months and just work like
crazy
this is think of it as the safety of
your family by the way what do you do
for a living
i'm a sales manager
are you planning on getting fired
no
yeah i think get it done can you do this
yeah
yeah absolutely i followed the question
now i am investing in my retirement
because i have a match do you think i
should stop stop pay it off
everything off they're coming for you
man they're coming for you and your
family until you get it paid off and
here's the thing andrew when you stop
taking that match you're gonna do that
for a short amount of time it's gonna
drive you crazy and i want it to drive
you crazy but when you go slow you can
go fast and when you have all of your
income back in your life you can invest
way more than you're currently investing
and so the math is going to work out in
your favor if you do the if you do the
baby steps this way
thanks for the call man appreciate it
melissa joins us in canton ohio melissa
welcome to the ramsay show
thank you so much thank you george and
john for having me today on on the air
we're glad to have you how can we help
um well my husband and i are in baby
steps six awesome and
thank you
um we are
super stoked about paying off our house
um as fast as possible so
i'm 32 he's 29 and we both have
full-time jobs
and
we
bought our house for 170 000 and we
still have about
86 000
left on the mortgage
we have a i have kind of a double
question here but um
to begin like
we have ten thousand dollars in a mutual
fund um in investment and
we're
all of a sudden like starting to think
about that money and think that maybe it
would be smart for us to take it out and
put it down right now on the house to
try to lower the mortgage
but we've also considered leaving it in
there um and using it towards kind of
the end of our mortgage to pay it off
faster do you have any suggestions or um
kind of can help us with that
um because we just want to get our house
paid off asap so i love it well i love
your intensity around this
you have 86 left and you have 10 and
this is just sitting this is
non-retirement right this is just like
in a general brokerage account
correct we have about 50 000
in retirement and my husband's
contributing 15
awesome well you're doing everything the
right way and if i'm you guys i'm
cashing this mutual fund out and
slapping it on the mortgage and when you
see that progress you're going to get a
little giddy up in your step and you're
going to be even closer to paying this
house off so that's my take and i'll
tell you that as a guy who is 32 years
old and i'm 12 days away from paying off
my house what 12 days john
hey so i was about to i was about to say
melissa you're living parallel lives i
am i am pathological about paying my
house off too i was about to challenge
george to who can get it done faster
don't challenge me and i'm
super not doing that
but hey you said we you know we've only
paid off this month you put this ten
thousand dollars you're basically
halfway home so flip it around and say
i'm 32 and i've already paid off half of
my house it's incredible you guys are
doing so great keep at it call us back
when you're debt-free mortgage and
everything you guys are doing awesome
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
still on baby step number one huh
how'd you guess with health care costs
rising learn how christian healthcare
ministries can help you make the most
out of your budget visit
chministries.org budget don't worry
it's worth it
[Music]
so
[Music]
big news guys christmas is only 22 days
away we know you're planning to do a lot
of giving this year that's why our team
has put everything on sale we've
extended our biggest cyber monday deal
to last till the end of the week so you
can get up to 79 off right now we have
special deals for everyone on your list
which means it's the perfect day to get
christy rice 2022 gold planner my friend
dr john dolone's questions for humans
conversation cards those are super fun
and ken coleman's career assessment and
they're all the lowest prices of the
year so hurry up get gifts for your
friends and family maybe even yourself
you can shop our cyber monday sale at
ramseysolutions.com
and remember we've got another fun
giveaway happening our ramsey christmas
cash giveaway this year we're giving
away 500 every single week and a grand
prize of five thousand dollars you can
enter every single day to increase your
chances of winning and you can go do
that at ramseysolutions.com
giveaway
this is the ramsay show i'm george
campbell host of the fine print and
entree leadership podcast joined today
by dr john delaney host of the john
doloni show both of your shows have
different names that's so cool yeah
thank you i tried really hard on that
you guys didn't try at all
i just didn't have the pool you have i
have so much creative creative pull here
well give us a call let's talk about
your life your money the number is
triple eight eight two five five two two
five and next up we've got brandon in
grand rapids michigan brandon welcome to
the ramsay show
how are you guys doing today doing great
how are you
i'm fantastic how can we help it's an
honor speaking to you guys
you too
um
so i got a question i've got a goal to
become a decca millionaire um and i just
wanted to get you guys an insight on um
maybe what i should do like
i'm following the baby steps i'm in baby
steps four and six
um
so when you're in baby step seven you
just continue
to invest in
your retirement and just cash like use
cash for everything or do you maybe
looking to like run a real estate or
single stocks um i just want to get you
guys an input on that before you answer
that george why why a deck a millionaire
why'd you pick that number
is this a goal of mine um
i don't know i just i'm an overachiever
i guess i don't know is this a personal
goal how old are you
27
27 and you're out of debt do you have a
mortgage currently
i do okay
well man you're you're on track to do
some big things i mean i think it's
possible it's a cool goal i think what
john's trying to get at is just kind of
curious about the voters
behind it is it like was it a number do
you want to get an airplane do you want
to have like some
is it a lifestyle thing for you neat
cars like what do you yeah what is it
um i think
it's sort of i guess like yeah it's a
lifestyle thing maybe um also i just
want to like be able to care for like my
family like
um just have enough money to i mean one
to five million is is great i know dave
says
um the baby steps is the quickest way to
get to one to five million and that's
awesome um i just
i wanna you know i've got like a dream
car a dream house i wanna have another
house down south and so i guess it's
just a lifestyle thing sure well at 26
dave tells the story but
he was bankrupt had zero
less than right
and now he's worth hundreds of millions
of dollars so the answer to your
question is yes you can do that
following the principles and how do you
do it that's a different question and it
sounds like you're already investing 15
of your income how much do you make
right now
uh 80 grand a year okay and i'm pretty
much at the i'm pretty much at the top
of my industry so
um i wasn't sure if i had to like maybe
switch careers
or i'm working with a um
with a investment pro what do you do for
work
i drive a semi truck locally
and you can't make more than 80 in that
industry
it's pretty much at the top i mean i
work
quite a bit hours like 10 to 12 hour
days
can you see yourself doing this for 40
years
that's the thing is i don't
i don't dislike it but it's not like my
passion but running the numbers like
i should have three to five million in
my retirement accounts by the time i
retire and a pension and so that's not
bad
but i would like to that's incredible
that's not bad
god almighty yeah we'll go slumming it
with five billion dollars in the bank
come on man there's a few things you can
do here and obviously you run the
numbers to see if i just invest 15
percent for a long period of time
multiple decades i can get up to 5
million now there's other things you can
do that we would say are wise things
dave loves real estate and so if you
want to do some real estate investing
once you have a paid for house you can
save up with cash and do that do not
take out more debt at that point but
that can help you build a portfolio
build that wealth to where you might
have 10 million dollars in assets
now can you get 10 million dollars in
cash in in your retirement account sure
you might need to have a great income
max out your 401k for the next 30 years
which you could easily do
and that could give you 10 million
depending on the rate of return so what
i love to do john is i like to go to
ramseysolutions.com and i go to the
investing calculator and it's fun to
just play around with the numbers and
you go all right if i invest a thousand
dollars a month for 30 years with a rate
of 10 where does that get me oh cool
that's 7 million okay what if it's 11 oh
that's now 8 million 9 million what if
it's not a great time and it's 7 okay
that still gives me 4 million and so you
start to play around with those numbers
and you kind of get excited and makes
you feel like you're on track and so i
think you aim at that and i think if you
hit nine million you call it good and
brandon let me can i can i just
be honest with you just love with just
two dudes not even on the radio in front
of millions of people just two guys
hanging out
yeah absolutely if you work for 40 years
in a job you don't like
and you have three million dollars in
your account
it won't be worth it
you've got an opportunity right now at
27 to do something that you love what do
you what do you want to do
what would you love to do
um well i looked into doing um being a
financial like master coach training
yeah um so i thought maybe i could do
that and build a client base um i
already help people for free just
because i love talking about money do it
both do both
real estate um
do both do both man because then you can
you can do your trucking and you can do
your driving you've got a steady income
and you've got a great opportunity to
build a side hustle
and man some of our coaching clients do
incredibly well for themselves
and you begin to lean into what i was
put on this planet to do i want you to
hang on the line brother um and we're
gonna send you a copy of our friend ken
coleman's brand new best-selling book
from paycheck to purpose
about like stepping back dude you're
making 80 000.27 you're killing it
you're doing great
but what i'm telling you is 40 years
from now at the end man if you've worked
for a paycheck man it's great take care
of your family i don't want to poop on
three million dollars for real
but man right now you are somebody who
is thinking ahead you're somebody who's
intentional and i want you to think
about
man if i could really lean into what i
want to do do i want to run run my own
trucking company do i want to run my own
coaching practice like what do i want to
do man and we're going to give you that
book and it's got the steps to walk you
through that is that cool
awesome i appreciate it so much i love
your podcast by the way i listened to
that podcast while i'm driving way
better than george's right that hurts
i'm just kidding
you guys both i love both both no i mess
with you thank you thanks brandon hey i
want you to keep those great goals keep
them out there but i never want you to
forget why you're chasing down that
money okay
all right
very cool i love it and on top of that
on top of sending you from paycheck to
purpose ken coleman's new book uh we're
gonna get you plugged into his get clear
assessment and this is really gonna help
you dial in what was i put on this
planet to do because that's a big
question it can get a little existential
and ken's assessment does such a great
job to just put it on paper you get to
read a sentence that can really start to
point you in a direction
because you're in the trucking industry
that's a tough industry yep and it's
tiring it's exhausting you're away from
your family sometimes obviously you're
doing it locally now which is great but
i want you to really dig in because i
think whatever you put your mind to
you're going to be great at it you have
an awesome work ethic you're thinking
ahead and like john said we want you to
be doing something for the right reasons
something that gives you purpose that
gives you a little pep in your step in
the morning and you'll get there man and
whether it's 3 5 10 million dollars we
just want you to look back and say man
that was a great life i lived and i want
people listening to hear this isn't
about the dollar amount i talked to a
guy the other day that makes 48 grand he
looked at me and said dude i'm in my
dream job dude i was high-fiving him it
was awesome it's less about the money
and more about man what is going to fill
me up and allow me to accomplish my
financial goals too you can fill your
tank and your bank account at the same
time if you do it right i love it this
is the ramsay show
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
you're listening to the ramsay show i'm
george campbell joined today by my
co-host dr john deloney
and on the debt-free stage in the lobby
of ramsey solutions chris and kara join
us how are you guys doing well we're
great little birdie told me you're dead
free we are congratulations thank you
where are you guys from uh well we live
in mckinney texas which is about north
dallas yeah yeah about 30 minutes north
alaska don't get them started on texas
yes we love texas i know i could see
your hats and your barbecue
but actually i'm i'm from from franklin
i grew up here so oh nice well welcome
back home as well so how much debt have
you guys paid off
uh 46
500
wow awesome how long did that take about
18 months we did it in 18 months yep wow
very well done and what was the range of
income during that time uh started out
at 80 000 and then uh up to 135 heck
yeah great income wow what happened
oh that's a good story
you want to tell it well
we started out probably 10 years ago
with more like 80 000 in debt honestly
and it's all for medical bills
unfortunately but when we were really
able to start shoveling and making some
major progress
chris got a really great job that he
loved in events
and then he lost his job yeah it was it
was just right after covet hit so of
course
yeah your dream job yeah yeah and we
were finally making some progress so
that was kind of
uh killer yeah but then
you can let me continue
we uh kind of fell into a side hustle
that ended up exploding because say you
went from 80 to 135 yeah what the
majority of it we did while he was
unemployed
what was the side hustle we started
flipping furniture oh my goodness that's
incredible it's kind of funny it's one
of those things i think it was like a
god talent that he just gave us that we
didn't know about right um it was
probably three days after i lost my job
we were kind of sitting there and just
going what are we gonna do and i mean we
literally just sat there and prayed
about it said okay lord you know we put
this in your hands and we know that
you're going to lead us and guide us and
he actually came through i mean just
a week later i mean it's one of those
things where cara was like i tell you
what um i've always wanted our bedroom
furniture changed because it's so
outdated i mean it's what 18 years old
and it was a cherry so it's really out
of style so she's like hey why don't you
since you're not doing anything why
don't you go ahead and paint this
this weekend and i was like chris you're
not busy yeah i was like i don't know
how to do this so
we watched a couple videos and you know
what i just went to town and over the
weekend and uh we redid our furniture
and she just happened to put it on
facebook and it was just like uh look
what we did we did it over the weekend
and everybody just started going oh my
gosh we do ours which i was like yeah
i don't want to i don't want to mess up
your furniture
so
it turned into an incredible job yeah
yeah what was the most you guys made
from like one flip
or one project maybe about eight hundred
dollars yeah
off a dresser good off a dresser yeah
wow
is this this your gig now well i was
able to step back from my job entirely
um he ended up getting a new job at the
beginning of what uh december a year ago
a year ago uh next week so i worked for
makita okay yeah right now so i'm in
sales congratulations awesome very cool
and you're just flipping furniture yes
and i stepped back from my job i used to
be a billing consultant for insurance
companies and things like that so um the
furniture was doing so well that i was
able to step back and run the furniture
business instead you mean you'd rather
just run the furniture business and talk
to insurance billing yeah no way
shocker no so what kind of debt was this
oh it was medical that was all yeah all
medical
what what happened
um when my son when our son was three
and a half he was diagnosed with autism
uh okay yeah and so the treatments that
were helping him
uh were not covered by our insurance oh
wow so we continued to take out credit
cards to
get into contamination
yeah yeah so and at the time we were
really living paycheck to paycheck so
and it was always like you know we would
we had taken the the awesome thing about
the story is right before he was
diagnosed we had taken um financial
peace university
so we knew we were we were there you
know we were ready and we didn't have
any debt previously we were already
ready to tackle baby step number three
and then that happened yeah wow and so
getting through it we knew what we had
to do when we got to like a point where
we could stop you know
what was this point because this is a
while back but 18 months ago something
changed what happened that got you on
this journey
oh we i mean since we just knew that we
had to do something it was mainly just
me losing my job i was just like oh my
gosh we've got to just cut back and
we've got to get back to the dave ramsey
and start doing the budgeting i mean at
that point it's just a matter of we've
really got to budget everything every
penny that kind of spooked you and you
said never again we're getting ready
forget it right never again and then
going through the unemployment was
really like
you realize the importance of having
that three to six month emergency fund
because she just
that feeling of
how are we going to put food on the
table
is real you know
at that point in our life it was just so
real so
yeah once once he got back on his feet
and the furniture thing took off we were
like we're going game on game on so oh
that's awesome yeah we just started baby
step number four so we're very excited
oh congratulations huge how does how
does it feel to breathe with a fully
funded emergency
it's so incredible it is so incredible
and i i don't mean to be dismissive here
but if you lose your job this weekend
it's going to be annoying it'll be
annoying
exactly it'll be frustrating you'll get
angry it won't be catastrophic right
right
wow what a financial incredible
transition exactly and the neat thing is
that we are like i call ourselves like
the king and queen of side hustles
because we were we are always looking
for a side hustle even when um we lift
paycheck to paycheck it was like
whatever we could do on the side to
start chipping away at this and then um
through furniture flipping we were asked
if we were ever thought about doing a
youtube channel and so we started a
youtube channel about six months ago we
got monetized really quick awesome yeah
so now we make money in our sleep off of
people watching us flip furniture online
great this story's come full circle it's
really neat america right yeah that's
right yeah so what do you tell people a
couple like yourselves they've got the
kids they're sitting with this debt they
feel the anxiety what do you tell them
the key to getting out of debt is
oh i would say don't give up yeah um i
mean i know there's a wide range of
people that are listening to this but um
you know no matter where you are if
you're in baby step one or two i know
it's hard and i'm sure you know a lot of
us are just used to spending you know a
certain amount of money and then all
sudden you're in this position where
you're like i've got to just budget
every single thing and it's going to be
hard you know and but i would just say
you know it's it's easy to quit but
don't do it um it's worth it uh if you
haven't gone through financial
university definitely do it uh it's a
small investment but it's something
that's really going to change your life
um i mean like you said earlier it's
just one of those things where i mean
the whole
that weight is just lifted off and i
mean each time you make a milestone
whether it's you know cutting up a
credit card or whatever getting to the
next baby step is just so rewarding um
so don't give up it's worth it it's
incredible and you've got the kids with
you today bring them up
what are their names and ages
this is dominic he's 13. hey dominic and
this is scarlett and she's almost 10
next week
and they got to watch their parents
sacrifice yes claw get out of this debt
change their family tree change their
legacy yes i love it well we've got a
copy of dave ramsey's brand new book
it's not even out yet you get the
advanced copy baby steps millionaires
that's definitely your next chapter as
you change your family tree and we also
have a copy of the total money makeover
that you can give to someone who says
how the heck did you do this all right
you can say furniture flipping and dave
ramsey that's right i love it all right
you guys ready you've been practicing
we're ready let's do this thing all
right ready it's chris and kara and
dominic and scarlett from mckinney texas
46
dollars paid off in 18 months making 80
up to 135 flipping furniture doing the
youtube channel count it down let's hear
a debt free scream
three
two one
[Music]
that is where it's at
awesome i could do that all day long
awesome what an incredible couple
when in doubt just side hustle it out
there you go oh they were resilient
nothing was gonna this was an incredible
clip until you started rapping just
sorry you're right usually you're the
one rapping i and i'm great chris and
cara just had a great story and you
tried to rhyme it up here john you're
right that was a downer that's all right
well they they really uh are an
incredible family it's amazing and would
you say when in doubt
side hustle side hustle it out no one's
ever gonna tweet that it's never they
shouldn't but that's chris and kara's
story hey we're proud of you guys you're
amazing couple what a great family thank
you all for inspiring all of us this is
the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
you're listening to the ramsey show i'm
george campbell host of the fine print
and entree leadership podcast on the
ramsey network joined today by dr john
deloney and uh john you've got a new a
new thingy out that has been going it's
been going bananas and
it's a it's a deck of cards called
questions for humans and here's the
thing over thanksgiving my wife was like
hey make sure you grab a pack on your
way out that's all i want to do this
thanksgiving i don't know what did you
pay her for that i did not
but they started these cars started with
um
folks writing in or calling in saying
all right deloney i turned all the
screens off i'm trying to be connected
to my family whatever the heck that
means and now me and my daughters are
just staring at each other in the living
room what do we do now and i realized
man many of us for years have been so
disconnected from our families that we
don't even know how to start that first
conversation it sounds so trivial
yes or we go to dinner with our
boyfriend or girlfriend or spouse and if
we're not talking about politics not
talking about covid and we're not
talking about our kids we don't got
nothing else to talk about or with
grandparents you're like god please
don't mention that and with the little
ones so we created a pack for families
like and thinking about young kids and
and grandparents and parents something
to do in the car going from school
that's not just how's your day fine
that's not a good enough answer it's
fine
one for friends just people hanging at a
bar grabbing a drink or grab a coffee
and then we got one for couples
so let's do one real quick okay we're
doing it live all right doing it live
this is a true random selection i'm
going to choose a card from the deck
this is very dangerous oh this is a fun
one what's the most overrated holiday
oh man don't hurt anyone's feelings john
yeah you can't say that i'm about to get
us canceled i know what do you think it
is uh you know i'm gonna go valentine's
day you hate love huh no i just hate the
the anxiety of like we gotta get the
reservations it's to be on this day
you've got to do it this way and so we
just decided you know what just getting
a pizza and writing a card celebrating
each other is enough for us but the the
marketing around it so let's go back to
my original question why do you hate
love oh my gosh listen it's your turn to
answer john what's the most overrated
holiday it's gotta be like a major
holiday you can't choose some random
yeah probably halloween really yeah hold
on the guy who's addicted to sugar yeah
thinks halloween's overrated it's
because of that it's because it's like
diabetes appreciation day it's like a
it's it's a terrible holiday where we
all just take one night we're like how
about we all just die a year earlier by
shoving john's officially renamed it can
we do one more sure absolutely okay yeah
before james takes us off the air here
all right all right
randomly here um
oh this is a tough one
who in the room is most likely to become
famous why
is neither of us neither of us yes i
wish ken coleman was here because he
would have said himself he would have
said can call you said absolutely he's
got the best shot
i think i think you have a better shot
john because you are uh you know you're
you're interactive tall handsome guy
okay continue you have musical abilities
continue you've got two phds
keep going now i'm done that's all
you're getting from me yeah i was gonna
see you but i think that wouldn't be
true i think i'm most likely to be
famous i tried i had a youtube channel
of 14. it didn't pan out didn't pan out
but here i am actually i think james
child is because
yeah he's the only constant around here
he's going to be here forever that's
right well hey these cars are really fun
i want to encourage people to uh grab a
pack for the holidays as they make the
road trips they're traveling they're
with their families you go to
ramseysolutions.com
and you can even get the bundle and
you'll save a few bucks by getting all
three and they really are a lot of fun
it sparks some cool conversations they
have sold like we i don't we way
underestimated way underestimated how
much the demand yeah how much they're
helping people
reengage with it's great
i'm one of those people who's like
addicted to their screens you know i'm
one of those millennials i've got
devices all over and i i realized oh my
gosh 20 minutes went by and i didn't
look at a phone and i actually feel
pretty good right now your body said oh
thanks george it's incredible then you
fixed it by looking at your watch and
your phone and your screen yeah there
you go well let's take some calls here
the number is triple eight eight two
five five two two five lindsay joins us
in columbia south carolina lindsay
welcome to the ramsay show
hi thank you so much thanks for taking
my call i enjoy all your podcasts oh
thank you so much how can we help today
well i have um a quick two-part question
um my husband and i or my husband
actually has a
really nice 2021
dodge ram
2500 series with a cummins engine
wow
we don't need that workhorse we sold the
camper
selling everything and getting out of
debt we are completely debt free except
our house way to go and so we're
wondering if we should sell that to put
on that money on our house and get
something to the trucks paid for um
the truck is paid for okay that's good
news what's left on the mortgage he had
a little windfall he had a little
windfall and some stocks he paid cash
for the mortgage is 145. how much is
truck worth
um he just got offered 52 from a
dealership so maybe a little more what'd
you guys pay for the truck
we paid what do we take the truck 50.
wow so you can make money on this thing
and get out of
it okay so hey the only reason you're
calling us lindsay is because one of you
wants to keep it one of you wants to
sell it
no surprisingly i think you should keep
it i said you love it it's paid for
we'll get out of the house and mortgage
debt anyway just keep it but he says no
we can get there faster
what's your income
household i'm about 380. 380 a year
yes sir
hold on well this changes some things
for me john
because if you love the truck
keep the truck pay off the house anyway
yeah pay off your house in six months
but more than that
lindsay do you realize what kind of
husband you have
99 of these calls are wives saying my
husband loves his truck more than me
i know we're just both in a hurry to
finalize our last i mean we owed well
over two hundred thousand dollars in
student loans just two years ago
busted it
yeah how old are you two
um i am 59 and he is 70. and what do you
do to make 300 000 a year
i'm a nurse anesthesiologist wow well
done
business
very cool
well i mean you guys are at a point
where it sounds like the goal of paying
off the house is more important than
having a sweet truck right now
so is that what we asked ourselves is
that more important i'm looking at the
priorities and saying hey could we buy
this truck again a year from now or
let's say it this way it's a right now
because you don't have a camper
um you so let's take the money off the
table you you make a jillion dollars
you've got no debt and you're paying off
your mortgage and you only have a
hundred and seventy left on your house
145 145 because you're right there at
the end
and he's talking about selling that the
next year
he can smell blood
your husband can smell blood he if he
sells this thing for 50 then he's gonna
be under six figures on that house
payment he can just feel it
um
so really the question is do you want a
50 000 toy
and you've got the money to have a 50
000 toy um you got a husband saying
honey i want to sell my 50 000 toy and
buy a 20 000 toy
and
i think you should let him do it but i
also think it does i mean it's just it's
a values decision for you guys well then
the other question is that we have our
we don't have a a huge um
retirement plan we've got about um
half a million six hundred thousand in
there now but of course i have more
years to work and we have about 20 000
in just um a brokerage account because
we're maxing out
um my retirement should we take that 20
000 out of brokerage and throw that on
the house as well
i would just leave it there because you
can you can stock that back up real fast
and be investing once that house is paid
off you free up that mortgage payment
now you've got a lot of ammo as you
start to save for retirement as you head
into you know hopefully not working
forever how much is this house worth
600.
so when you say not much you're a
millionaire
right
well yes
yes you're a billionaire that was a
rhetorical question from john there's
the only answer is yes congratulations
so if i'm in your shoes i'm gonna cash
out the brokerage account take that 20k
throw it on the mortgage sell this truck
get something reasonable right now
because guess what a year from now
you're not gonna have a mortgage anymore
and you can buy a sweet truck no
the mortgage just went down to 75 000
then there you go doesn't that feel good
make it happen congratulations call us
back when you do your debt-free scream
and we're going to be cheering for you
i'm pumped about this i mean i know you
love a good truck john but not that much
not that much no i'd rather have a paid
for house and be millions all day every
day that's what it's all about good hour
john fun times thank you so much for
being a great co-pilot here
thanks so much to james childs our
producer ben hill our operating board
engineer austin selby our phone screener
and you america we'll be back with you
before you know it this is the ramsay
show
[Music]
hey it's kelly associate producer and
phone screener for the ramsay show if
you would like to do your debt free
scream live on the show make sure you
visit theramsieshow.com and register we
would love for you to come to nashville
and tell dave your story
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studio it's the ramsay show
where america hangs out to have a
conversation about your life and your
money i'm george campbell ramsay
personality and host of the fine print
and entree leadership podcast and i'm
joined today by my co-host dr john
dolone fellow ramsey personality
best-selling author and huge fan of the
band poison there's a fun fact for you
huge huge
so we're gonna go to the phones this
hour it's a free call triple eight eight
two five five two two five call us up
we'll talk life money relationships
mental health whatever's on your mind
zach joins us in huntington west
virginia zach welcome to the ramsay show
hello
what's up how can we help
uh yeah i was just calling because
me and my wife are kind of at a
crossroads um
we didn't want to make it so that she
could stay home with our son we
determined that's financially like
impossible we couldn't
afford it
but
we were wondering if
it would be a wise thing to do to
go part-time and be in debt for like 10
years or
at the track we're on right now we can
pay it off in two years if she works
full-time and if i worked full-time
we were wanting to do that get out of
debt so we could stay so she could stay
home with my son and
we really want to get involved in some
ministry in
some more economically depressed places
in some rural areas so
but we we need to be more financially
stable to do that so i was just
wondering what you guys thought about
that
um yeah man i mean
that's a pretty wide gap
and eight years swing there who one of
y'all wants to stay home and one of you
wants to to work
do both of y'all want her to stay home
we would i would like her to stay home
and she would like to stay home too but
how much debt do you guys have
eighty thousand dollars and what's your
income
um
our income with her involved is one
hundred thousand she makes seventy
thousand she's an engineer and i'm a
teacher and i make about thirty five
thousand
okay and you're saying if you guys
stayed the course both kept working you
could pay this thing off in two years
yeah and if she decided to stay home and
you guys lost the majority of the income
it would take 10 years
yeah absolutely no-brainer you'll suck
it up for two years work like crazy you
be a teacher and then you deliver pizzas
at night and then you wait tables on the
weekends
and you get that 30 up to 45 and you
hustle and grind and get this thing done
and once you owe nobody anything and
you've got some safety net that's why i
want you to hustle because i want you to
go over this i want you get an emergency
fund
and then you're gonna be able to breathe
you're gonna find some things out about
yourself about your marriage and then
um
let this be the
the
jet fuel for the next 18 to 24 months
get this stuff knocked out and then
y'all can make some decisions about what
you want to do but you'll dug yourselves
a big hole man you got to get this thing
done you don't want this hanging around
for 10 years it's going to haunt you
are you guys doing a monthly budget
right now
yeah we started it up again we had kind
of fallen off the train but we're we're
back to it
um
so yeah we've we've been doing that
again and we're trying to
get a hold of our finances zach can i
ask you a hard question
yeah um and i need you to know my
background my mom's teacher my wife's a
teacher my dad's a teacher i've been a
teacher like that's my whole family okay
um there's you're not gonna find
somebody else on the radio that's got
more respect for teachers than i do
you have a set of goals for your family
you have a picture of what you want your
family to look like your wife does too
and that includes her staying at home
raising kids and not being in the
workforce can you see that picture
through at 30 000 a year
debt-free
in west virginia it i know people that
do it i'm not i don't care about other
people i'm asking you
can you um can you raise your family on
thirty thousand dollars a year
um probably not thirty thousand easily
no um
i'm going to get my master so that i can
raise up to four to closer to fifty okay
that's that's what i was going to ask
you is this the season when you all have
a conversation about
i know what i want to do and i know what
i'm good at is there something inside
this system like so you're a teacher is
there something like being a an
assistant principal is there something
about going into the admin side of the
dark side right or if i get a graduate
degree and does that help me here can i
adjunct classes whatever that looks like
for you
but how do you make enough money to see
your family picture
become a reality uh oh
you got a master's degree is what i i
need to do okay now if you're gonna do
that you gotta cash flow it don't don't
do all this crazy work
and get out of debt and then turn around
and get right back into it right well i
have a i have a scholarship to liberty
university right now okay so for your
master's the whole thing
yeah yeah it's through the west virginia
baptist convention get it done get it
done get it done yes and if you can if
you can put the grind in for the next
two years and raise your salary 15 20
000 bucks do it do it do it thanks for
the call zach all right let's go to dan
in san francisco dan we're running up
against the clock here let's get right
to your question
all right real quick um for you guys um
i am i'm a wife and i are deaf free now
after finally getting serious with
everything and i've got a question about
uh baby four five and six the baby steps
there
um
i'm a police officer out here in
california so i have a defined benefit
pension that is based on my years of
service
and it is
not funded by my employer but i pay 13
out of my
paycheck
to
fund this pension
so i was just um looking for some
clarification on how much of that
percentage do i apply to the 15 of baby
step four
because i got three kids coming up on
college that i haven't
started much for college savings and i'd
like to put as much to baby step five as
possible sure so this is a mandatory
contribution from your own paycheck at
13
that's correct
into a retirement vehicle that you don't
get to control
correct are you
are you in a union
yeah okay
man it's like a state pension that is um
so
it's all based on my years of service
the only option that i get when i retire
is there's like no lump sum option
i can just pick
um how much of my pension
i want my wife to get should i die first
it can it can be a defined benefit for
her going forward as well so so
let me get this right
i i guess in theory but let me let me
make sure i've got this right
a a government agency or a union agency
is telling you
where you have to take your money and
what amount of money you have to take
and put it in their vehicle
and then they're gonna tell you at the
end of it how you get to use it
um yes
here's the thing dan
exactly we're gonna count that at about
half and so instead of 13 look at it
like six and a half percent which means
you need to put in another eight and a
half percent of your own money to get to
that baby step for fifteen percent
because of what john talked about it
performs poorly you don't have control
over it so i don't wanna count that uh
and it's in its full amount so that's
what we do we counted at half you put
another eight and a half that'll get you
to 15 and we hope that fingers crossed
it all works out
this is the ramsey show
[Applause]
[Music]
if you're not using puretalk for your
wireless you're paying too much puretalk
gives you the same great 5g coverage on
the same 5g network as one of the big
guys for half the cost the average
family saves over 800
a year go to puretalk.com and choose the
affordable plan that's right for you
with their 30-day risk-free guarantee
you have nothing to lose go to
puretalk.com and enter the promo code
ramsey to save 50 off your first month
[Music]
guys it's almost time for christmas 22
days away and for some of you when you
hear that word you just think of stress
how you're gonna pay for presents the
bigger grocery bills and all the other
stuff but it doesn't have to be that way
when you have a plan for your money
you'll have confidence even when
everything else seems out of control and
that plan is financial peace university
you'll learn step by step how to get out
of debt save money and build wealth in
fact the average household saves twenty
seven hundred dollars and pays off 300
in debt in just the first 90 days and
right now fpu is only available in a
ramsey plus membership you don't have to
live with a stressed out christmas year
after year make 2022 the year you
finally start winning with money get
started today
or you can give fpu as a gift by
visiting ramseysolutions.com
fpu that's ramsey solutions dot com
slash fpu i'm george campbell joined
today by dr john delony and you are
listening to the ramsay show open phones
this hour triple eight eight two five
five two two five give us a call and we
would be happy to talk about what's on
your mind jason joins us in tallahassee
florida jason welcome to the ramsay show
hey george and dr john thanks for taking
my call absolutely how can we help
okay so
uh my wife and i have 13 years we had
we had three houses together we each had
one before we met
and we bought one together
we just sold the one that we bought
together and we made a handsome profit
and i'm kind of wondering what to do
with that cash and here's kind of the
conundrum
um my house is paid for her house is not
and her ex-husband is responsible for
paying her note by their divorce
agreement
so she wants to just keep all this money
in savings and i'm thinking there's got
to be something better we can do with it
how long have you been married
13 years 14 years
i don't hear a lot of couples who've
been married 13 years
still referring to her house in my house
tell me how that works i mean we've
never we've never consolidated we i
owned my house outright before we met
and she was supposed to own her house
outright when she got divorced
and we've just left them in each of our
names i i actually live at her house i
rent my house out
and all of our
all of our bank accounts are joint the
only thing that's not joint is
the titles on these houses
would it change your psychology in your
home if you referred to these homes as
y'all's homes and suddenly you've got
another guy
you know what i mean
we
we do and i actually suggested that we
just pay hers
off um i mean we've got you know 200k
sitting in the bank right now is there
accidents they're still living in a boat
on her house
yeah i'm living in it so is she no no is
her ex-husband still living in it
oh no he's got his own place but he's
paying the mortgage as part of the
divorce agreement
yeah she was supposed to get the house
outright and he's not on the dave's plan
of paying it off in any big hurry
and you guys are living she wants to
we're living there she wants to let him
keep paying it as long as he will but
he's sort of running a failing business
dude sell the house and get out of that
mess this feels like a weird situation
the ex-husband is getting paid
for where you're living that
yeah the house is in her name
sell it sell it in her name sell it but
there's still a note on it
sell it get out of the mess get her
ex-husband
stop paying your rent
get out of it yeah i mean like you got
to change your like your house and my
house and then our house bro you've got
three houses y'all are married for 13
years you all your family has three
houses start using that language
and then well two at this point
i could get her husband out of it by
just paying it off
and her take on it is that lets him off
the hook for what she is owed
and she's playing a 13-year game of
vengeance and
all she's doing is killing herself
slowly
i i don't care what you got to do man
get that guy out of your life you got to
pay the house off sell the house and
move into the other house sell that
house and take all that cash and buy
y'all a house together that's new for
whatever you got to do man get that guy
out of your life
what's the what's left on the market on
that
good what's left on the mortgage
108 and you have 200 in the bank
correct which means if you paid it off
today you'd have 92 000 does that
include your emergency fund and
everything
uh no i've still got an extra emergency
fund over that i'm fully invested in my
traditional ira don't have a roth i need
to do that
well what i would do is like john's
saying if you pay that thing off you've
got 92 sitting in the bank that you can
do anything with and you have a paid for
house you don't have a payment in the
world then you can decide hey do we want
to get into more real estate do we want
to be in the real estate business and
get some more properties what do we want
to do with this money and you could max
out your retirement accounts have you
ever had cancer
no
okay
you do you have a cancer
and you can solve that cancer with a
hundred thousand dollars
if i'm you in your financial situation i
would do that for the days over
and that man's name would be voldemort
in my home and we would just be done
saying it
jason what happens if he can't pay the
mortgage he said he has a failing
business let's say he can't make the
payment doesn't that put you guys at
risk that's the point we have enough
cash to but she wants it to just sit in
a savings account just in case he can't
pay it she wants to punish him get him
out of your lives let him go let him go
be free
he hey you know what he drug it out for
13 years he won golf clap
congratulations man you beat the system
high five way to go
we're rich we got lots of money we're
baby steps millionaires and i'm cutting
my wife's ex-husband out of our life
forever i'm gonna live in my house that
this doesn't even have a note on it and
my ex my wife's ex-husband's no longer
going to pay my mortgage that's the move
thanks for the college cancer out
interesting situation all right sean
joins us next in atlanta georgia sean
welcome to the ramsay show
hey all right it's good to be here how
can we help how you doing
um i'm just kind of
confused about what i need to be doing
with my finances in the next couple
months
i'm actually joining the marine corps
and shipping out in january
congratulations brother way to go man
thanks for your service
oh no thank you it's a it's an honor uh
i just kind of i'm curious about what
your opinion is on what if i do with my
savings that i've kind of just held in
the bank account go off okay how much
savings are we talking
um
between six and eight thousand
okay and is that all the money to your
name
no sir i do have a little bit in
stocks and
stuff like that but
just like single stocks
yes sir okay
and how old are you
21 21 and you don't have any debt
no sir have you saved up an emergency
fund
yes i have so that's outside of the six
to eight thousand
yes sir okay
dang man there you go dude 21 years old
you're doing better than most of america
yeah so way to go and you're wondering
what do i do with the six to eight
thousand while i'm in the military so
that it can grow for me
yes sir how much do you have in the
single stocks and all that
um about about three to four thousand
okay
well the single stocks worry me a little
bit because of the volatility and the
risk there i would rather have you in
some good growth stock mutual funds that
are diversified with hundreds of stocks
and so if i'm you before i join the
military i'm going to cash those stocks
out and i'm going to park it with my
savings and you if it's going to be how
long are you going to be in the military
for
a five-year term as of right now
okay well with that kind of time horizon
you can put your money in the market but
i would not do it in single stocks i
would park it in some good gross stock
mutual funds diversified across four
types that's what i personally do and
you can work with smartvestor pro to do
that at ramseysolutions.com get
connected with one in your area in the
atlanta area before you head out and
that way you'll have what almost twelve
thousand dollars that can be growing for
you over five years and some great
mutual funds and you might have a rate
of return of you know nine ten eleven
twelve percent while you're gone and you
come back to a big pile of money
how's that sound all right
it sounds great to me
and when you get out give yourself a
month before you go buy a big jeep my
brother all my buddies get out of the
military and go get a big jeep just wait
make sure you got the cash dude 21 years
old you got your whole life ahead of you
guys way to go thanks for your sacrifice
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
if you're considering a career in
technology i recommend bethel tech and
i'm not alone here's what brendan said
before bethel tech i was driving uber
within four months of graduating i got a
job paying 60 000
about two years after that i got a
remote job that pays me a hundred and
thirty thousand dollars all thanks to
what i learned at bethel tech you could
be next get started today at
betheltech.net
and get one thousand to twenty five
hundred dollars off of your tuition
again it's betheltech.net
ken coleman
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you're listening to the ramsay show i'm
george campbell ramsey personality host
of the fine print and entree leadership
podcast joined today by my co-host
dr john delony
you know john we get a lot of questions
lately about cryptocurrency yeah that's
cool man it's all the rage and we
actually dove deep into this on the fine
print podcast with a 30 minute episode
called could bitcoin be your ticket to
wealth and it was fascinating as we dug
into it and my takeaway in the podcast
is this i'm not mad at cryptocurrency or
bitcoin i'm not against it no man i
think it's all valid but there's a time
and place you should be dabbling in it
there's a right way to do it so you
don't screw up your financial future and
uh this article that i came across is
fascinating it's from wtop local news in
washington dc and here's the headline
that grabbed me
can you buy cryptocurrency with a credit
card
oh hooray
the answer spoiler alert is yes yes
and uh
this is what uh one of the financial
professionals here that's interviewed
steve larsen he's a co-founder of
planner dao cryptocurrency education
community for financial planners he
actually teaches classes on this stuff
and they said much of the chagrin of
some financial professionals and here's
what he said if you wouldn't buy shares
of apple stock on your credit card you
shouldn't be putting putting bitcoin on
your card either yet many people do so
every day
and so the article goes on to talk about
how depending on your card issuer and
the cryptocurrency exchange platform you
can in fact use a credit card
go into debt to buy cryptocurrency
this is frightening times we live in
john wow you can't just buy single
stocks you can use imaginary money to
buy and that imaginary pieces of
imaginary money
my mind just exploded is that incredible
or what uh incredible in a bad way yeah
this is frightening wow
and here's what it turns out to be there
are so many fees involved with this
process uh coin mama is one of the
exchange platforms where you can do this
you can use your credit card to buy and
they charge a transaction fee based on
the market rate which can fluctuate plus
two percent they also have a commission
of up to three point nine percent and an
additional five percent fee if you
choose to buy with a credit card so
let's say you want to buy a thousand
dollars worth of crypto where you're
going to pay 109 in fees alone yeah only
to possibly lose it all anyways so
here's what it feels like to me
um
if i'm the average person at home i'm
hearing about crypto i'm hearing about
it i'm hearing about it i'm looking at
some of the world's wealthiest men and
women saying dude you got to get in on
this get in on this i've created my own
i've created my own i got my own
platform my platform's got a feed is
your platform have a fee with my
platform and talk to you i'm just
feeling like
i'm getting behind like everybody's got
a smartphone without except for me
everybody's got a car with gas and i'm
still in my horse right
and so
they're making it easier and easier and
easier for us and we're feel we're
feeling we're missing more and more out
on things
i love going back to man nobody's hating
on crypto going back to if you're if
you're trying to buy crypto as a hedge
against a monetary policy that's when
you're a bonkers that's a whole other
phone call but
but if you wouldn't buy
stock
if you wouldn't go invest in your
friend's company on a credit card like
if you wouldn't make that kind of
nonsensical move
don't buy imaginary money
using imaginary money well said on top
of that this is fascinating too the card
issuer so the credit card company on top
of all those fees i mentioned they treat
this as a cash advance and so that comes
with much higher interest rates and a
five percent cash advance fee and so
they go on to talk about the pros and
cons and hilariously this is one of the
pros they mention
you can invest without having the cash
on hand
that's real that is a recipe for a
financial disaster
it's gambling on a credit card if you
wouldn't go to vegas on well people go
to vegas and credit cards all the time
so i don't know at least vegas is
entertaining there you go but they also
mentioned this is a pro you can
potentially earn rewards on your
investment you can get credit card
rewards john
fantastic this is genius we're hacking
the system so listen if you feel like
you are missing out
and you don't have you may be let's be
you may be
but if you don't have money
you can't afford it
john that hurt my feeling i know it does
and you only have three of them left i
only have so many left
don't buy something you have no money to
buy it
they do close in a way that makes me
happy here they talk about this crypto
is already a volatile investment and by
purchasing it with with credit as in
money you don't actually have it's a
sign you can't really afford to lose
that money this is from the news they're
actually saying this way to go news if
your crypto investment loses value it
compounds those losses and it ends with
this great quote from steve who they
interviewed i have found most people who
purchase crypto on credit aren't focused
on building a portfolio they're trying
to reduce their exposure to their least
favorite asset class
that's a mic drop from steve larsen way
to go steve don't let fear of missing
out plunge you into debt don't do this
i'm not mad at crypto if you want to do
it and here's what we tell people john
get out of debt have a fully funded
emergency fund be investing 15 into
retirement that means 401ks iras things
rooted in reality
and then if you've got some fun money
that you want to spend you want to take
100 bucks and buy some doge or ethereum
or bitcoin or you want to take a
thousand bucks and that's money you're
willing to lose as in if you set that on
the table and lit it on fire you
wouldn't be too sad
you go well we had fun that's like vegas
right you bring 200 bucks to vegas you
play some slots you go home but it's
when people get in over their heads and
it becomes obsessive i mean this is a
hobby this is and you get more expensive
than golfing yeah you get over leveraged
and it gets frightening yeah so do it
the right way
don't have the fomo have what i like to
call jomo the joy of missing out i love
not investing in crypto how long did it
take you to come up with jomo a few
years that's a work in progress that's
great it's not great all right you're
really talented i'm over two today john
that wasn't great i thought we were
having a good time but turns out that we
were having a great time till you joe
mode the whole segment all right well
that's crypto for you folks open phones
this hour triple eight eight two five
five two two five we're happy to take
your calls on life money relationships
whatever you wanna talk about ethan
joins us from the great state of texas
ethan welcome to the ramsay show
thanks for having me guys i'm really
excited to talk to you guys yeah um
so really quick the question i have is
should i be looking to pick up a side
gig or a side hustle
um in the next few months a little bit
of background my wife and i are
expecting our first in january
yeah
yep so it's gonna be a little boy we're
excited um the other thing is my wife is
stopping work for the baby obviously and
she's also transitioning her career
right now into real estate so probably
you know
q1 q2 of next year she'll start in real
estate
um
and yeah and the other thing is we're on
baby step three and we need about
fifteen thousand and we only have about
two thousand right now
and i'm going to be on parental leave
for about 12 weeks once the baby's here
so what do you guys think
uh
man
have you sat down to talk to your wife
about this
yeah we've talked about it she's open to
the idea but um
i guess doesn't want to detract too much
from like the attention we're going to
need to have here at home yeah um so
it's kind of on the fence we're both on
the fence a little bit i usually
recommend to folks who
are about to have their first kid and
the house isn't on fire and your house
is not on fire you do want to get out of
debt you're working a plan oh you are
out of debt i'm sorry you want to build
an emergency fund right
yeah yeah so things things are urgent
but they're not on fire um
man you think you know what's about to
happen you got no idea on and not in a
bad way in 20 different ways
you think you know what not being tired
is you got no idea you think you know
what love is you got no idea you think
you know what frustration is dude you
you know what i'm saying so um
you think you love your wife now you
it's just an amazing process and so
i think man having the conversation
having the ideas um setting up the plan
do you have a side hustle in mind
uh not necessarily uh they're hiring
like crazy everywhere because you can
just like deliver pizzas um we're doing
doordash right now for fun that's like
15 an hour after like gas and stuff
absolutely can you pick up some holiday
work before baby gets here
yeah i certainly could i guess like
putting up lights and stuff like that
for people well even just seasonal
seasonal work at retailers i mean people
are paying big money right now just to
get you to get through christmas so if
i'm you i'm doing everything i can right
now to hustle before the baby's here i'm
working my tail off
yeah and save up right now you're in
you're in stork mode so we're not trying
to build this up we're going to put this
aside make sure baby's safe mom's safe
and then we can go all right this has
now become our emergency fund and not
the baby fund
the way to go man we're happy for you
good luck getting that emergency fund in
place you got this this is the ramsay
show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
our scripture of the day comes from luke
11 13.
if you then though you are evil know how
to give good gifts to your children
how much more will your father in heaven
give the holy spirit to those who ask
him
henry wadsworth longfellow said give
what you have
to someone it may be better than you
dare to think
lisa joins us in roanoke virginia lisa
welcome to the ramsay show
thank you hey gentlemen how can we help
today so
i am one of five siblings
our oldest brother passed away in late
october
i'm so sorry sorry to hear that thank
you
so we are um we're sad we're emotional
we are very angry at a situation that
happened um during his hospitalization
with his girlfriend
and
i'm the executor of the will
and i have the full support of my
siblings and our spouses
but i just want um to make sure that
because we're so emotional that we have
healthy boundaries and that we're not
acting out of revenge and yet are being
good stewards we want to have biblical
principles
but it's all a bit confusing right now
so
my brother and his girlfriend had dated
about nine years about two years ago she
moved into his home
but they never combined finances and he
is the only name on the d
um to the house and on the mortgage and
she is not mentioned in his will
they have had a
rocky relationship for the whole nine
years they just
fought like teenagers had horrible
boundaries
um
they would not speak for days one of
them would leave and go stay with
somebody else they tracked each other on
their phones
just
things that the rest of our siblings
were concerned about we mentioned it
my brother-in-law
liked the relationship and honestly they
never brought many of their problems to
our family gatherings and we loved them
both we actually enjoyed being with them
there were lots of good times
but we knew the relationship was not one
that any of the rest of us would have
wanted sure
during the last two weeks when my
brother was in the hospital
the girlfriend
got angry over
some of my female friends
texting encouragement to him
she said some really ugly things she got
mad over
a niece taking clothes to my brother
instead of her daughter
um
just childish squabbles
she said horrible things to him did some
horrible things with their security
cameras
wouldn't let him have access to
electronics she was monitoring his
social media
to the point where he wanted to end the
relationship he was sobbing to
our husbands our children some of his
friends
and
individually and collectively my
siblings and i had decided that we
didn't want her to be
a part of our family gatherings if when
when if we were hoping at the time that
he would recover
and we were
we knew from the history that there was
a good chance he would forgive her and
we needed to have a tough conversation
with him about our new boundaries but he
didn't recover
and on the day he passed he asked to see
several of us and her
and he told us that he had forgiven her
and it didn't matter why she'd done what
she did
but we still don't want to have anything
to do with her and i
she doesn't seem to want to have
anything to do with us sure but we have
to deal with her because there's a house
she's still living in the home
sure um
so i don't want to be mean but i want to
do the right thing sure
so number one
i'm heartbroken for your loss
i can tell it's heavy on you and your
family and what a mess
i want an unexpected yes
um thank you i'm gonna say something
that i hope isn't controversial i don't
mean for it to be i've just walked
alongside people in this situation
um
grief
and watching a loved one slowly slip
away
makes people do things they wouldn't
normally do makes them say things they
would normally say makes them react in
ways that is just
out of character
um
and so i
i tend to be
real forgiving
in those situations because for you
she's girlfriend she's basically been
his wife for 10 years and their
relationship was way different than
yours but it's the one your brother
chose over and over and over again
and so definitely what i think's hard to
not do is to go back and retroactively
judge his relationship and then
determine what you think the right thing
to do is
based on your interpretation of his
relationship
at the end of the day he chose this
quasi marriage even though they weren't
married but they acted like it they
played it for a decade
and they did so
i i think to
if i'm you i'm not gonna carry that the
stuff that happened in the hospital i'm
gonna let it go because it's gonna it's
gonna impact my grief and my memories of
my brother and i'm not gonna give that
power to her yeah okay i'm not gonna
give her that power
then i'm gonna say what would my brother
want me to do with the estate
what would be the best way to honor what
my brother told me even on his deathbed
what's the best way i can honor my
brother with his as a steward of his of
his finances
and that's a hard hard thing what did he
leave you guys
probably nothing financially okay
um
ironically
three of us are every day
well three of us are debt-free including
the mortgage and the two older of us are
everyday millionaires
um
one
one of us is not quite
out of a mortgage but we're all stable
and his finances were
totally opposite so we we expect
that that house is fully mortgaged and
there was a car payment and some medical
debt but we don't have that information
um
and the girlfriend has not wanted to
provide it yet so if i is the will going
to probate
it will have to yeah so y'all go to the
program
y'all will work all that through here's
what i would recommend
because i'm gonna i'm gonna say
something's hard okay
y'all are this isn't about money
this is about this is about anger
and this is about hurt
and i can't tell you what a blessing is
to talk to you because you know that you
are grieving hard and you want to do the
right thing not through the
not through a lens of grief but through
a lens of compassion and what my brother
want and that's such an honorable thing
for you to it's raining on you
and you're still walking
towards a path of integrity it's it's
what an honor okay um i would sit down
because this isn't about money this is
about
um yeah i don't like her and she really
screwed up in the hospital and she made
the last few weeks of your brother's
life hell for y'all and you'll have to
live with it yeah
um the question you'll have to ask
yourself is is it worth taking her home
away
the home that they shared for a decade
or for two years or five years away is
and there's no money to be exchanged
here right it's not like you're
you're not having a million dollars i'm
trying to discuss here it's a matter of
saying i don't i don't even think we can
keep the home
well but it is there there's probably a
common law uh situation here where she's
gonna have a claim to it and if she can
make the pain you know what i mean
they're i'm sure that will pop up not in
our state oh not your state okay wow
okay
yeah
wow okay
can i ask you let me ask you this
what do you think the right thing to do
is as hard as it might be what's the
right thing to do
well
what i think we would have done
if the last two weeks hadn't happened
is we would be grieving together with
her her included
and we would be
helping her make a plan
to move
in
four or five months when the wheel's out
of probate and we know what the
financial situation is
so
here's going to be a
my recommendation
our recommendation is you reach out to
her and you say that
say the last two weeks we're a mess and
we're heartbroken
we're willing to walk alongside you if
you want us and she can say no and then
you dust your hands off and you move to
the next town
but that's what i would do
beautifully said john
sorry for what you're going through that
puts this hour of the ramsey show in the
books thank you so much to my co-host dr
john deloney our producer james child
ford engineer ben hill and our phone
screener austin selby we'll be back with
you before you know it this is the
ramsay show have a friend or family
member that needs a daily dose of ramsey
advice in their life let them know about
the ramsey call of the day podcast it's
a quick hit of advice about life and
money in under 10 minutes check out the
ramsey call of the day podcast wherever
you listen to podcasts
[Music]
you